en pleine période de pont printanier il
est habituel pour les professionnels de
l'hôtellerie de miser sur le mois de mai
ont lancé la saison haute
qu'est ce qu'on dirait comme chambre
soir à l'image de l'hôtel de bourgogne
un établissement trois étoiles situé à
deux pas de la gare ferroviaire de mâcon
la cuvée 2010 9 à un groupe plus amère
qu'en 2018 avec un taux d'occupation
deux fois moins important sur les 59
chambres
c'est une dizaine de chambres par jour
donc ça fait important à peu près
d'occupation seulement et bâle c'est
calme c'est très très calme mais on
espérerait effectivement pour un début
de saison on espérait une activité un
petit peu plus soutenue le calendrier
joue à cache cache avec le secteur
hôtelier avec un premier 1 8 mai placée
à mercredi sans compter une météo
capricieuse ces paramètres peuvent
plomber l'ensemble de la période
estivale
tiens moi qui normalement on tourne à 75
80 % de taux d'occupation
donc là et cette année on va on va être
je pense au moins 15
15 % en dessous de 6 s'est pas si c'est
pas pire les établissements de saône et
loire toutes catégories confondues
restait sur deux années ensoleillé avec
des taux d'occupation flirtant les 60 %
en mai contre 70 au plus fort de
l'activité estivale
tout comme les gîtes et les campings du
département pour l' agence
départementale de développement
touristique
il est impératif d'anticiper la saison
haute avec la promotion par exemple des
courts séjours avec les actions que l'on
mène de communication et puis si on a
une bonne météo
on aura sensiblement et probablement
plutôt une bonne saison 2010 9 du parc
zoologique de romanèche thorins ans à la
basilique de paray-le-monial et ses 4
159 visiteurs chaque année où la roche
de solutré l'ensemble du secteur
touristique attend la fin du mois et le
jeudi de l'ascension pour définitivement
lancer la saison estivale